si vous aimez le saumon fumé
vous êtes gâtés en épicerie ce n'est pas
le choix qui manque
nous avons recensé une quarantaine de
produits fumés à froid fumée à chaud
artisanales ou industrielles
et il ya même certaines épiceries qui
fait muller seulement sur place le but
de proposer un produit fumée sur place
et donnent une image artisanale à
l'entreprise
le chef laurent guerchais collabore
régulièrement avec les restaurateurs et
les épiciers qui veulent apprendre à
bien fumer le poisson sur le marché
il y a quatre espèces de saumon sockeye
arc en ciel ou ce tir aide en anglais
atlantique et koro un peu de saumon
sauvage mais surtout d'élevage d'un peu
partout on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'élevages aujourd'hui mais ça permet
aussi de préserver les ressources et ne
pas tout détruire dans la nature aussi
on peut avoir du très bon très bon
élevage comme du mauvais la chair d'un
saumon de moins bonne qualité est
facilement reconnaissable
on va avoir une chaire plus molle moins
facile à travailler également est
déchiré ça va se déchirer exactement
alors qu'un saumon bien élevé sera
stenay quand on voit les rainures d'agra
pour moi ça veut dire que la poisse on
avait vraiment un riche et embauche qui
va se tenir la tranche stone est si
difficile sous un emballage se trouve
sur du poids du congelé ou évidemment là
on a une texture dur donc pas c'est pas
facile puis malheureusement n'a pas
forcément toujours là pour le nom sur
les emballages
parce qu'on voit sur les produits
préparés ok veut pas dire que c'est un
poisson du québec
en effet comme il n'ya pas d'élevage ici
il y à fort à parier que les poissons
dans nos barquettes de saumon fumé
québécois viennent surtout du chili le
plus grand éleveur roman dans notre
échantillonnage seulement les paquets
provenant de cinq marques affichent
clairement la provenance du poisson fait
des grèves choix du président
irrésistible d'hommes et vasco
[Musique]
laura boivin est une passionnée de
saumon fumé
elle nous accueille dans son usine de
saint augustin de desmaures
j'aime occupe personnellement des achats
de seulement pour notre vie que ce soit
de l'alaska que soit la
colombie-britannique du chili peppers je
vais personnellement visité chacun des
producteurs sont par exemple se caille
sauvage je viens de l'alaska
à peine quelques heures après que soit
péché on veut le congeler quand tu
arrives et c'est notre usine
on va le déjeuner dans l'eau courant
pendant 24 heures une fois que on va
avoir mis le poisson au filet on va voir
retirer la ligne d'arrêt centrale les
nageoires la pression vont installer le
sel n'est pas un élément conservation
c'est vraiment donner un petit peu de
goût et puis lorsqu'on va appliquer par
la suite le sirop d'érable
on va empêcher l'appréciation plus
grande du sel dans la charge du saumon
mais la presse on va l'envoyer au fond
noir quand on fume à froid comme ici on
donne une saveur de fumée au saumon cru
sans le cuir chez grizzlies on fume 24
heures à une température de 10 à 16
degrés celsius dans le cadre du fumage à
chaud le saumon est cuit car la fumée
est à une plus haute température
facile à reconnaître on le retrouve
généralement en pavés ou en filets plus
épais zappons science montre qui fume et
boit l'érable et un veau fruitiers on
peut fumer à partir de diverses essences
de bois et même avec de la tourbe
aimer de papeete images on va leur dire
une température très précise au dixième
de bugs et les frais je voudrais pour
pouvoir par la suite le trancher c'est
surtout du saumon fumé à froid qu'on
trouve en épicerie déjà sonné on sent
vraiment le poisson en premier c'est
super important
la réputée chef caroline mais cannes se
joint alors engagée pour évaluer une
vingtaine d'exemplaires de produits de
saumon fumé à froid acheter réfrigérés
ou congelés j'aime bien retrouver le
goût du poisson en premier on doit avoir
un équilibre des saveurs poissons les
fumées
le fumer est quelque part un
assaisonnement donc parlant
d'assaisonnement la teneur en sodium des
différents produits varient entre 455 et
1400 mg une énorme différence
les prix varient de 63 à 130 dollars le
kilo c'est à dire que cette portion de
100 grammes peut passer de 6 à 13
dollars et beaucoup de spéculation que
ce effectué un marché non seulement il
va avoir des variations très importantes
tu veux jouer sur l'offre de la novembre
si on compare les deux d'un paquet à
l'autre la couleur varie beaucoup
et ce n'est pas un indicateur de qualité
la nourriture intervient beaucoup dans
la coloration du saumon naturellement le
second qui mangent beaucoup de crevettes
rail angle va être plus intense en
couleurs donc évidemment il ya peu de
crevettes à disposition dans les parcs
dont on a des colorants ajoutée ou
nourriture pour intensifier la
coloration du poisson
dans l'ensemble ce sont tous des
produits nets accents ont mis un qui m'a
pas vraiment enthousiasmé le reste
n'était tout à fait correct deux
produits de saumon atlantique se sont
démarqués et bonne nouvelle
ce ne sont pas les plus chers ça goûte
presque saumon frais ce lieu c'est très
délicat pour sa délicatesse c'est la
fédé grève fait de saumon canadien qui a
ravi le plus nos bouteilles le choix du
président a agréablement surpris avec le
goût particulier de son saumon écossais
fumé au bois de shine un excellent
produit et ce malgré un taux de sel plus
haut que la moyenne 50 pensent un peu
mais ça va patins pourquoi est-ce que
c'est très sale et celle de loin le plus
sympa
400 millions de cette transition au
final les experts s'entendent pour dire
que la majorité des produits sont très
bien alors peu importe votre choix
le saumon fumé avec son bon goût et sa
haute teneur en oméga 3 saura
accompagner vos collation ou plats
principaux
on peut les intégrer dans tout dans le
fond n'importe quelle race est que ce
soit du déjeuner dans une frittata
jusqu'au souper avec un petit canapé
vite fait comme ça suggestion de
caroline tartine tea time au mascarpone
sur pain de seigle rouleau printanier
concombres carottes et fenouil canapé
avec salsa au kiwi jaune et crème
fraîche
robert est bon avec des poivrons
c'est très différent ça
[Musique]